[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais présenter Spider-Man
et to spiders un film d'animation de
2018 qui est le premier film ou ensuite
du coup miles morales qui est une des
nombreuses itérations de Spider-Man dans
les comics et pourquoi c'est un film que
j'ai envie de vous parler c'est que non
seulement c'est un film qui a à la fois
à transformer un petit peu le monde de
l'animation avec un espèce de mélange de
2D de sidji qui n'avait jamais été offre
auparavant quand on regarde ce
Spider-Man on a l'impression que c'est
les pages du comics qui prennent vie je
m'appelle miles morales je suis le seul
et unique Spider-Man du moins c'est ce
que je croyais l'accélérateur de
particules qui connaît tu vas adorer
dimension en cours
d'ouverture
comment c'est possible on a l'impression
de voir le papier on a l'impression de
de sentir vraiment toute cette façon là
et ça n'avait jamais été fait vivement
c'est voilà ce n'est pas que du dessin
ce n'est pas que de la pure 3D ça se
passe de mix hybride et ils ont été les
premiers à le faire et donc déjà rien
que pour ça ça vaut le coup et surtout
parce que on peut souvent avoir des a
priori en temps sur les signes
d'animation tant que l'animation avec
une technique et pas ça veut pas dire
que c'est pour un âge particulier que
ces trois choses la façon juste une
technique différente mais Spider Man
c'est un film très mature sur les sujets
très très fort et sur l'adolescence sur
grandir sur qu'est-ce que c'est que le
poids des responsabilités et c'est un
film qui sous couvert encore une fois de
film d'animation on se dit allez c'est
pour les jeunes pour les enfants
j'allais le voir et bah qui même en tant
qu'adulte je peux vous dire vous prend
au trip et vous amène sur une histoire
que vous y attendez pas et voilà c'est
je pense tout style confondu pour moi
des meilleurs films de super-héros de
ces dernières années
et c'est donc un film à voir
[Musique]